robert carro
author of the years of lyndon johnson
means of ascent in the back of your book
you admit that you looked at 629
000 pages of documents or at least they
were put in front of you how in the
world did you read all that
well i spent a lot of years on this
and a lot of those years a lot of months
in those years i spent in the lyndon
johnson library
you call up these boxes it's actually an
estimated number because they said the
exact number of boxes in it
that i called for is whatever is in
there 787 or something that's right and
they said that in a full box you have
800
pages so that's uh so you just sit there
you know when i was a newspaper reporter
just starting out i was at 20 and i had
this editor
who told me turn every page never assume
anything
and uh with his early life at least it
was physically possible
to look at every piece of paper how much
new information is i know that's a tough
question to answer but
a lot of new information in these books
this is your second book well i think
it's
a pretty largely new information because
uh
lyndon john you know when i started this
there were already
17 biographies of lyndon johnson and i
felt that his youth
in his early years i would hardly have
to do any work on
because i thought they had been covered
over and over again
but when i went to texas i started
finding out
that most of the stories that we knew
about and the anecdotes so we knew about
him were really a legend
that he had uh in effect created about
his life and it wasn't really
the truth so i had to start all over
again
can you remember the moment the first
moment that you said
i want to do london johnson well i was
my first i was a reporter on newsday and
what i realized was not that i wanted to
do biographies brian
i never conceived of writing books just
as the lives of famous men i really had
no interest in that at all
what i wanted to do was explain how
political power worked
because i was a reporter and i was
covering politics
and i felt that i wasn't really
explaining what i had gone into the
newspaper business to explain
was governor or or mayor who was he by
the way well
robert moses was this park commissioner
of new york and the chairman of the
tribal bridge authority he built
every bridge that's been built in new
york since 1930 the verrazano throgs
neck bronx white stone henry hudson etc
he built every mile of expressway and
parkway that's been built in new york
uh since the 1920s all the parks he
either built or rebuilt
he created so much of the landscape of
new york
the book is called the power broker and
i really picked that title
because uh he wasn't elected to anything
he got
power from extra democratic means such
as the public authority he created
public authorities
in their present form but i would be a
reporter and
no one knew this including me and i
would be sitting there and you type city
park commissioner robert moses and i'd
wonder what did that have to do with the
fact that he built the long island
expressway
well you type triborough bridge
authority chairman robert moses and you
say well
what exactly is an authority you know we
thought it was just something that built
one bridge collected tolls and went out
of business
so i really wanted to examine how urban
political power worked
i thought i could do it through the
means of the life of robert moses
and all the time i was doing it see i
never thought i'd get to do another book
because we were just broke the whole i
had a tiny advance
no one thought anyone would be
interested in the book on robert moses
what i was trying to do was finish it
what year was this
well it was i it took me seven years it
was published in 74 so
i guess i began in 67 i was just trying
to get done so i could go back to work
you know as a reporter but i knew that
if i ever
somehow could i'd like to do the same
thing for national power
as i had done in the power broker with
urban power and i knew i wanted to do it
with lyndon johnson
because i felt he understood national
power better than any other
president in our time what year was that
well the power broke was published in 74
and i
shortly thereafter started on the lyndon
johnson biography what was it though
about lyndon johnson that got your
attention
well what kind of regard my attention
was when he was senate see with moses
everyone said
no one ever did this before what he did
right he was never elected to anything
but he had more power now with johnson
they said the same thing no one ever
dominated the senate of the united
states
like lyndon johnson did he control the
senate majority leaders i said well if
no one else did it if i can find out how
he did it
and show how he used power how he
obtained this power
used that was what first got me
interested
and what did you do first first i went
to texas
you walk into the lyndon johnson library
the first two floors are a museum
then there's this huge staircase and on
top of it
are four floors there's a glass wall
with four floors
of the papers of lyndon johnson uh
they're all
whatever there are they're 34 million
documents
they're all in these boxes red buckroom
boxes stamped with the
presidential seal and gold and they
tower up
four stories all right that was the
moment i thought of quitting
actually and then of course for the next
few years
we spent a lot of time my wife einer and
myself in texas
i want to ask you a personal question
i'm not sure you want to answer it
ask it anyway how do you afford to do
this kind of thing you spent seven years
on robert moses
and you spent 14 years on london johnson
who pays the bills during these periods
well it's very different you know for
the first book
i did for a tiny advance i think was a
2500
advance i nobody was really interested
in the book
and really we were just broke pretty
much for seven years
i got a grant for one year but i thought
the book was only going to take one year
you know
so at the end of the year i was just a
reporter we had no savings
we had a house on long island so we sold
that
but um that was before the real estate
boom
so that gave us enough money after the
mortgage for only 15
more months we moved into an apartment
in riverdale in new york
and from time to time i know my wife
would go to work but i also
needed her to help me with the research
on this and
that was a continual struggle i mean to
do the power brokers i look back on it
well for the first five years or so then
things
change but for the first five years or
so it was just a struggle from month to
month to keep going
then that was not a best seller at first
but it almost
immediately began to be used by really
hundreds of colleges you know in
different courses
and you know i won the pulitzer prize in
other prizes
and i was able to get a much better
contract
for lyndon johnson and then the first
volume of the johnson of course
was what their my major best seller or
whatever i know
all the money problems have ceased and
it's not even a consideration
is it true that they printed 500 000 of
the first lyndon johnson book
well they're 500 000 in print now yeah
more than 500
all hardback it's in it's in
all we we've never had a mass market
paperback i'm not sure if that figure
includes the trade paperback with the
various hardback
additions uh i i that figure that you
gave me
is what kanav says and they said it to
me and i
i didn't really ask what the different
editions the first book of about london
johnson was
on what subject what part of his life it
was
well it starts really before his life
because i wanted a show what life in
rural texas
you know was like and his ancestors
which i thought was such an important
part of his life
and it takes him up to the age of 32
when he has gets his first national
power
and uh at the end of that book he tries
for the senate that's the last scene
in 1941 and loses to this texas
campaigner
path past the biscuits papio daniel with
his hillbilly van
that's the end of the first volume he
has national power
but he can't move up to the center and
now the second book
focuses on only seven years of his life
it's after that defeat where he's stuck
in the house of representatives which he
really
dislikes and he cannot find a way to
advance himself politically
and his whole life these are his seven
years in the wilderness
it's his seven years he turns to making
money
with the radio station and he sort of
consumed
with his need to try to move up to the
senate
on what he always envisioned as his road
to the presidency
and of course centerpiece or whatever
you want to call it in this volume
is his last chance in 1948
he decides to take one last chance and
run for the senate he says if he loses
he'll leave politics forever how many
books
about lyndon johnson are you going to
write four what are the next two
going to be about well the next one
takes him from
being sworn into the senate to
up through his rise to power in the
senate his majority leadership running
for president against
jack kennedy losing and being the vice
president
it ends with the assassination with him
being sworn in on the plane in
dallas and then the last volume uh
will be the presidency i'm determined to
try to do the presidency
in one book because it's one story
read somewhere where you get a a
distillation of all this at the end are
you going to write a fifth book
well i want to do when i'm done yes i
want to distill it down
into a one volume
have you written the third volume
already well i'm writing it right
yeah this book we're talking about the
one that was just published
is to me almost you know it's behind me
that's the funny feeling
my mind is in the third volume now
johnson is in the senate
when did you finish writing this book
oh i don't know nine months ago ten
months ago so i think i don't really
remember
and do you think lyndon johnson all the
time
is it is it hard to get him out of your
mind
i well no
actually because you see because you
know large parts of the book
don't deal with lyndon johnson like in
the first volume i wanted to talk about
him bringing electricity to the hill
country no one had done that story and i
thought it was important
so i just went off to research
electricity
and rural electrification and he's not
even in it you know now in the third
volume
the great thing that he does is pass
this first civil rights legislation in a
century in a senate that's dominated by
the south
so i'm going back and doing the civil
rights history
you know so lyndon lyndon johnson is
sort of out of it for a while that's
what keeps it interesting you know you
keep doing
uh going off and doing other things
that are related to this book that's why
i call it the years of lyndon johnson i
wanted to show
american history during the years of his
life and not just his life
when you in your acknowledgments you
thank a lot of people from the lyndon b
johnson library in austin texas
how many years did you spend in the
library well
i can't answer that for 14 i've been
working on the book for 14 years
um and in each year
there there are months that i spend you
know in the library some less
than others i i don't i've never counted
that up we've also spent you know
a lot of time uh living
up on the edge of the hill country in
texas
so that i could interview the people in
the perdinalis valley where johnson
grew up people who grew up with him the
people went to college with him the
people who were his first political
machine
and i wanted to learn that whole culture
of the hill country so i could
understand him better
you were born where i was born in new
york city on central park west
where i now live what's the first thing
you noticed that was different about
texas
than more where you grew up texas was so
different you know i had no idea
and i the first i mean it was one
dramatic moment
actually it was dramatic to me i don't
know if it's dramatic to anyone else
but i'd never seen johnson sitting i had
no idea of the loneliness and the
emptiness of the hill country
so the first day i was there i rented a
car
and i drove out of austin and towards
johnson city and about 40
to 43 miles out you come to the top of
what they call round mountain but it's
just really a high hill
but from it you can see this really
vast basin or valley in front of you
miles long and miles wide maybe 30 miles
long maybe 15 or 20 miles across
and in this whole area you couldn't see
one sign of human habitation and then
the sun came
out from behind the cloud i had stopped
the car at the top of this thing i was
standing there looking down into it
and the sun came out and suddenly you
saw the sun glinting off the roofs
of this little huddle of houses in the
middle of this emptiness and that was
johnson city and i think i knew in that
moment i was getting into something
that i had not really understood
and then after that it was just a
constant you know you have to learn
about the loneliness there and the
poverty there
i remember sam houston johnson and his
brother
telling me how he and lyndon used to sit
one part of the johnson ranch butted a
road one corner
and they'd sit on the fence there at
that corner all day
hoping for one person to drive by so
they'd have somebody new
to talk to and the deeper i got into it
the more i realized gee i just don't
understand this
land this culture you know there was an
old post mistress in johnson city named
stella
glidden she used she said to me once
you know you're a city boy you don't
understand the land
and unless you understand the land
you're never going to understand lyndon
johnson
and i remember i thought oh baloney this
sounds like a grade b
western or something but i came to
realize
that she was really telling me something
that it was the struggle to survive in a
land where survival was so hard
that did shape a lot of johnson's
characteristics
so we moved down there and for large
parts of three years i don't know how
many seven
eight months a year we lived in houses
on the edge of the hill country
so that i could really sort of immerse
myself
in that land i want to read
an associated press story a quote
because i don't want to put words in
people's mouths because i want to go
back to the london
johnson library and ask you some
questions about it former johnson a jack
valeni has accused carroll of being
passionately meant on destroying the
late president's reputation
bob hardistia johnson speechwriter who
helped him write his memoirs called
carol's biography dishonest
quote i don't think it pretends to be
fair i think it is the work of a man
with a burning unnatural hatred for his
subject
hardest he said let me let you answer
those charges and then i want to go back
to the library
well i did i don't think there's any
truth in them at all
i think i let the facts speak for
themselves i'm taking people through
lyndon johnson's life
as he lived it chronologically nobody
disputes
that these are the things that he did
nobody has
challenged really anything that i know
that i
that i know i don't know of anybody
successfully challenging everything
as for disliking him that's not really
true the johnson loyalists
really dislike as you can tell even hate
my books that however does not mean that
i dislike lyndon
johnson i think that
the story of his life to me
is a very sad and poignant story
it's not a question of liking and
disliking
i'm trying to understand and make people
understand
more than that i'm trying to understand
people understand
i'm trying to learn how the political
power worked as he used it
and i'm trying to portray that now
that's a very unpleasant in
some in this volume it's a very
unpleasant story
um but that doesn't mean it didn't
happen
it doesn't mean that my portraying it
means i dislike when you do
back to the library did you notice a
change in the way people treated you at
the library
as they gathered you were going to be
critical
and the first volume was not uncritical
no right no but
but there were more bright sides because
see in the period of time
covered by the first volume he is doing
things
that we see things that are going to
emerge in his presidency for example we
see his compassion
for the mexican-american kids when he
was a school teacher
he toured mexican-american children down
in catoola
and i think i say in that book that no
teacher had ever cared if they learned
or not
this teacher cared you know he worked
with them ceaselessly
beyond you know anything that was
expected of him of course we're going to
see that in the civil rights legislation
when he's majority leader and president
and we see
in him helping his constituents such as
with rural electrification
this great gift that lyndon johnson had
for mobilizing the powers of government
to help the dispossessed but um
in this i forget what you you i want to
know
if the people at the library start
treating you differently no well
the library you know reminds me very
much of the rep
the situation of reporters during the
vietnam war
the people that i work with at the
library are the archivists
the uh they're historians professional
historians
who i think chose mostly to go into
archival work instead of teaching you
know at universities
and they're very anxious i think to see
the truth come out
they're very helpful however the
hierarchy of the library
um liz carpenter walt rostow now people
remember from the johnson years
of course disliked my books just as much
as the
quotes that you read do you
see them doing anything to prevent you
from getting the information
no who owns the library
well the library is part of the national
archives all presidential libraries are
part of the national archives
and so you have a right to anything you
want in the course of your research
well no it's more complicated than that
because johnson's papers were given to
the
uh federal government
under a deed of gift which was later
incorporated
in a will and that deed of gift gives
the library broad discretion
as to what they can close you know
anything that would harass or embarrass
someone
then they remove the document and
replace it with a pink slip
and quite often as you're going through
these papers
as you're going toward it you know
you're turning every page going through
the letters of the memos as you're
heading towards the crucial moment you
see a little line of pink slip
sticking out and it's often a crucial
document so what you really just try to
do
is keep going and looking in other boxes
and all you know and trying to
find out as much as you can did you have
the experience as you were going through
the files of when you found something
you knew was really special
did did you feel any sensation at all
yeah
with lyndon johnson the sensation is
quite often
one of real depression because uh
an example of that which was very
striking to me
was in the learning how he betrayed sam
rayburn you know
in the first volume we really see how
rayburn loved lyndon johnson
we can call it a father-son relationship
as a cliche but
rayburn was his great patron johnson
came to washington he was the assistant
age 23 24 he's an assistant to another
congressman
and rayburn is then the mighty majority
leader
grim fierce visage man that everyone was
afraid to approach with immense power
he was a very lonely man and he was
lonely because he had no family no wife
no children
he once wrote to his sister god what i
would give for a towel-headed boy to
take fishing
but he didn't have one when lyndon and
lady bird
came to washington uh lyndon's father
had known sam rayburn and
mr sam as they called him used to come
and spend sundays
you know have sunday breakfast and then
stay around in johnson's little
apartment
and he was very fond of both linden and
lady bird
once when johnson was still a young
assistant he got pneumonia which of
course was very serious back in
those days mrs johnson was back in texas
on a vacation
and rayburn sat next to johnson's bed
all night in the hospital in a
straight-backed wooden chair
he was so afraid was a chain smoke he
smoked all night
but he was so afraid of making a
movement and disturbing
that he didn't brush want to get up and
brush the ashes away so when lyndon
johnson woke up in the morning
sam rayburn was sitting there with his
lapels covered with this
cigarette ash as soon as he saw that
lyndon johnson was awake
johnson recalled rayburn leaned over him
and said
lyndon don't worry about anything if you
need anything
call on me and shortly johnson did call
on rayburn
rayburn got his career started and um
now it's 1939. john nance garner
and roosevelt have split garner was
always roosevelt's a man in texas
someone's going to be roosevelt's man in
texas the
dispenser of the new deal power and
patronage in texas rayburn was a
majority leader still or
unless he's become a speaker i can't
remember today
is the logical choice but johnson wants
that jaw
and to get it he persuades roosevelt
that ray
falsely that rayburn is his enemy
and i couldn't understand what happened
here you know
and i'm going through these boxes in the
johnson and i've interviewed some people
who were involved
and i'm trying to piece together from
the interviews and the papers
what's happening and there's never one
piece of paper there's no you know
there's never
one i document at least i never seem to
find one
it's always a series of telegrams and
memos and you can see the picture
building up
and the picture i mean it was so
it was depressing to me i mean i
remember uh to be honest with you that
my thought was
oh god i hope this doesn't mean what i
think it does
i and i got up i remember and actually
left the library and walked around
outside i didn't want to go through the
rest of the stack of papers
but of course i did and when you went
through it
the evidence was incontrovertible you
could see just what lyndon johnson did
so quite often with johnson the
reaction is depressing now the other
side of the reaction is thrilling see
with johnson there's always
two sides a bright side and a dark side
because in that
library are the letters from these farm
women
whose lives he transformed by bringing
them electricity i mean
uh they were living without electricity
on a farm where you have to haul up
every bucket of water you know yourself
from it from a well which in the hill
country was about 75 feet deep
really made slaves out of women and
they didn't have electric washing
machines or anything
his fight to bring electricity there
which seemed impossible because there
was no
source of hydroelectric power for miles
hundreds of miles and some for some
places
was really a noble example of the use of
the powers of government
to help people to do something they
couldn't do themselves no matter how
ingenious or determined they were they
were never going to get electricity
so johnson you know did this and you can
see these letters
you know thank you for bringing the
lights you know that's that's
a phrase that was used so sitting in
that library you have
is a very emotional experience sometimes
of course
it's also weeks and weeks of utter
boredom you know where you keep going
through boxes
and there's really nothing that you how
many hours a day would you work in the
library
well i always work it's only open nine
to five i'm i'm never tired at five
o'clock
i'm always working up to the last you
know minute that they allow me to work
in
now are you going to go back after this
volume and
continue to do work in the library sure
have you been back since people have
read this book
well no it just came out last week and
you haven't been down there
no since then um will you talk about
you have a chapter in this book devoted
to
his wife
and someone who is still alive uh lady
bird johnson and
do you have to remember what year this
photo was taken 1948.
and what was he doing in this year he
was running for senate against the man
on the other side of the page the man
with the pipe
coke stevenson who at that time was
well he was the former governor of texas
he was running for john
against johnson for the senate and the
outcome of this election
johnson won by 87 votes out of about a
million votes that were cast
and one of the points you make in this
book is that he stole the election
the election was stolen yeah and how do
you prove that
well i prove it it's not it's not
actually that hard to prove
just that nobody apparently uh did it
there are more than a thousand pages of
court transcripts see
hearings were held at this at the time
and more than a thousand pages
of testimony were taken in which all the
witnesses are testifying the same way
except for one that man was that one is
a man named louis salas who was the
election judge
in the crucial precinct box 13 and jim
wells county
now he testified to the opposite of all
the other people
i found mr salas in houston in 1986
he was then quite old but clear of mine
and i asked him about the discrepancy
between
his testimony and everybody else's and
he said well that's simple robert i lied
under oath
and he then told me
and took me in great detail through the
story of what happened in box 13
and this time his story simply
corroborated
what everybody else uh had said in this
photograph
uh bob carroll uh louis salas is over
here on the
it's on the we can see him yet over here
on the
no down the far as you're looking at the
screen the far right
no on the man to the bottom is louis
salas oh okay
right there as you can see uh louis
salas
there is this huge gun-toting
burly enforcer for george parr the duke
of duval
when i went to see him i guess i had
this mental image of that's what he
looked like but of course he was 84
years old
the man who opened the door for me was a
stooped
gentle rather frail old man
and golder and glass i want to get back
to mrs johnson but i want to ask you a
quick question have you ever met lyndon
johnson
i don't think i i once covered i was
just starting out as a reporter
in 1964 i was a substitute for the
reporters covering the johnson goldwater
campaign
people keep asking me that i had a
couple of days maybe four or five days
covering johnson but i was never
you know close to him i was never a pool
reporter or on the plane i saw him from
you know as a reporter when did he die
in 1973
of uh heart attack yes
mrs johnson you have a chapter let me
just ask you uh
first why did you devote a chapter
called ladybird
well i think that the story of lady bird
johnson's transformation which in this
book means of ascent is what late
the lady bird chapter is about is one of
the most
wonderful stories that i ever heard you
know she was so shy
as a girl she had this really painful
public shyness where she couldn't bear
to speak in public
when she was in high school she told me
she prayed that if she finished first
the second in the class and would have
to give a speech as valedictorian a
salutatorian at her graduation
she prayed that she would get smallpox
and i wrote she would rather risk the
scars than speak in public
now she marries lyndon johnson she of
course cannot
campaign for him make speeches for him
more than that she doesn't participate
in the political part of his life
at all and i asked her why not and she
said well
i didn't want to be part of absolutely
everything
now suddenly in means of ascent he goes
off
to navy service on the west coast and in
one
instant it seems like he has to say to
her now you have to run the office
for me and she has to go in having done
nothing
like this and be in effect the
congressman for the 10th district of
texas
and she told me about this and i talked
to the secretaries who worked in the
office with her
and to me i mean her story of finding
the courage
to make herself do things that she could
never bear to do
i mean one of her secretaries told me
how mrs johnson would sit in her
husband's big
chair behind his big desk and her hand
would be reached out for the telephone
but she couldn't bear to make the course
she'd have to call a cabinet official or
some high government official
and she couldn't bear to make it but i
wrote but she always made the call
i mean she told me about the day that i
had a call
that formidable mr icke who of course
was harold dickey's the secretary of the
interior the old curmudgeon
she not only had to call him she had to
go to see him and persuade him to revoke
an order
that adversely affected the 10th
district
and she did and he revoked it and
her story of and just of how she became
turned herself into the lady bird
johnson that we know
today with her poise and graciousness
and dignity
which to me it's really i just said i'm
going to tell this story
in full you did 10 interviews with her
yes
where well they would either be in the
library
or once or twice they were out at her
ranch she has an office on the line
and when you interviewed someone and by
the way how many interviews did you do
for this book
well i never counted it's obviously
many hundreds did you tape record them
no i don't type recording
long hand or short hand i i take i have
my own short hand
if it's necessary to get a paragraph or
two every word i
i can do that how come no tape record i
feel that it intimidates people i
intimidates may be the wrong word but i
feel
that i'm trying to get the truth you
know to find out what really happened
and i think that i'm dealing with some
very smart
and weary men smartest and weariest
i don't think men like that forget for
an instant that there's a type of
quarter running and whether or not that
they do
i don't want any barrier between um
their recollections and and and the
facts and i
feel like there is one i read somewhere
where you wrote a million words for this
book before the editor got to it
that was for the first book the power
broker yes the original manuscript
not a rough draft the polished
manuscript was a million fifty thousand
words
but we couldn't fit it all in one book
so we had to cut it down to seven
hundred thousand words and how many
words are in this book
i never kind of it's about five hundred
pages i guess it's about
two hundred and fifty thousand i never
count let me
read just a little bit this is almost
the last thing you say in this entire
book on page 425
although from the first i made it clear
to mrs johnson that i would conduct my
own independent research into anything i
was told by anyone
for some time she very helpfully advised
members of the semi-official johnson
circle in texas
that she would have no objection if they
talk with me last sentence of your book
at a certain point however sometime
after the interviews with mrs johnson
had been completed
that cooperation abruptly and totally
ceased
yeah why i don't know you have no idea
well i could speculate but it wouldn't
be based on any knowledge
what year was this always before
anything was published
many years ago i mean before the first
volume was published or any excerpts
and the inner circle would not talk to
you from that day forward
well no it's not true that no members of
the inner circle wouldn't talk to me
most of them have talked
i don't know i don't know what you're
really asking well my point is that
undoubtedly you put this in here for a
reason no i put it in there it's
actually not part of the book
it's a part of the note on sources in
which i try to explain where i got
you know the various pieces of
information and
therefore when you know i thought people
would want to know where
because a lot of the there are a lot of
quotes from mrs johnson in the book
because a lot of it came
from mrs johnson particularly you know
so i thought people would like to know
uh how i how how that those interviews
went that's what that's why i
explained well on the other side of this
is that uh john connelly supposedly
wouldn't talk to you for a long time
read the first volume and then what did
he do
then he called me well i i have to you
know
he called me and said very flattering
things about the first volume
and said that he therefore didn't want
me to do the second volume without him
and would i come down and see him and i
said yes and he said the only place we
can get
away from everybody else is at my ranch
so i went down to
his ranch and spent whatever three or
four days there now however
uh for whatever reason i won't speculate
mr connolly
uh says very differently
so um i mean about about my work about
your work
right of course in this book he is a
source you know in particular in his 48
campaign
he was one of johnson's bright young men
really the leader of the bright young
men in this 48
campaign and he talked to me quite
frankly that like he would not agree at
all with my conclusions but i'm sure
that he wouldn't
disagree with any that would say that i
misquoted him or anything like that do
you think that
because mr johnson put out the word to
all these people
and and they wouldn't talk to anymore
and if you don't want to speculate
the fact that they wouldn't talk to you
anymore did that hurt your
book well no because um i
would i refer to uh to there
it's not that they wouldn't i mean like
for this book the people who were
closest in this period just to stay on
this
because it gets too confusing otherwise
uh who were closest to lyndon johnson
with john connelly walter jenkins
horace busby warren woodward george
brown of brown and root edward a clock
perhaps 20 of them i named them
without exception 100 all talk to me and
talk to me
as much as i wanted at uh so
that's not really accurate there are
members of the johnson circle
who i wouldn't when actually just
a couple who wouldn't talk to me and i'm
sure i'll find more
but the fact is that each time one of
these excerpts ran in the new yorker
i couldn't keep up with the people
telephoning
or sending me letters or contacting me
through an intermediary to really say
why haven't you talked to me yes usually
it was because i'm not up to
i'm not up to them yet well one other
thing on the on the source thing
the greatest single lost in my research
in my opinion came with the death of abe
fortis
yes why well a you know in this
abe for this first place was very close
to lyndon johnson at crucial moments in
his life
now in this volume would be much poorer
johnson
saved the senate election because of a
legal maneuver
by abe fortes fortis explained it to me
and i think the book
is much richer for that i think
he died right between two interviews i
had an interview with him
and he i asked him a question he said oh
that's an important question we'll talk
about it
whenever in a week or whatever and we
made a date and then i picked up the new
york times one morning and
abe fortis had died very young of a
heart attack
that was i can't ever i mean that will
hurt my work
in my opinion all the way through
is there a difference between your work
as a journalist and the
professorial academician profes uh
historian type
i mean you approach the these volumes
differently and i know there's always an
argument about what is history
well i think that um there are a number
of
you know things that are important to me
one is the level of the writing
the thing that always mattered to me was
that my books endure
and i have a theory about history see i
don't regret my
books as biographies so much as i do
with history
so i call them the years of lyndon
johnson and
i feel that in order to endure a work of
history
has to be written the prose has to be at
the same level
as a novel that will endure and i don't
think there's enough
emphasis in the writing of a lot of
history
on the fact that this is a book if the
history is thrilling if the events are
thrilling
you're not being true to history if you
make it boring
if you concentrate just on the facts and
don't give a sense of place
sense of the people involved i think
narrative is important
and empathy is important
you went to school at princeton yes you
worked for how many years at newsday on
long island
i think six years you've done
a total of three books now yes
and you've got two volumes of this to go
yes
one of the things in the back that also
was
caught my attention was the two pages
that you wrote about your wife
you called her your quiet idealist
explain why you called her your quiet
idealist but what
how important was she to this whole
process oh she's an integral part of the
process she's
the whole staff you know most most
major biographies presidential
biographies if you look in the
acknowledgments in fact it's a whole
list of researchers and
archivists i could never trust other
people to look at papers because
you know only i know but einer knows
she's see einer is a great historian in
her own right
she's a medieval historian in fact she's
writing a book of her own
when i was writing the power broker
there was a time i was hurt
i couldn't get out of bed for a long
time and
i had to teach on i had a yanker away
from the middle ages she was doing
her phd thesis on education
under charlemagne and i had a her away
from that and send her out to
to really do investigative reporting
work for me
and ever since then we've worked
together and um
she's a wonderful historian and i guess
i
call her uh my beloved idealist
because she's beloved to me and she's an
idealist
you know i said quiet idealist but
beloved idealist and you but you did say
anna caro is quiet and calm and wise
but the last line i don't know what i'm
going to do without her help
yes which now she's writing her own book
what's that on it's a guy a travel
history of france through the eyes of a
historian so each time
you go to a castle or a chateau you're
not just looking at a building you know
all these things that happened there in
history wonderful story
you write about her
let's see if i can find it in pursuing
she crisscrossed the united states
spending weeks for example going through
papers of former senator richard russell
yeah in a library in athens georgia
those of willis robertson
who is the father of pat robertson in a
library in williamsburg virginia
and those are presidents roosevelt and
truman and hyde park and independence
missouri
uh why all those libraries and what did
you find there
that you hadn't already oh well you can
never do
you know you can never do uh just
a a work of history just from the the
one
source now when she was in the richard
russell library because
i'm going in great detail into johnson
as majority leader richard brevard
russell of georgia
was the great southern patriarch and
leader you know of the southerners in
the senate
and i wanted to know all about his
relations with lyndon johnson
so ayna went down to the russell library
uh in the truman library same thing you
know you try to go through we've gone
through the papers of many
senators of that period you know in
their own earl clements
papers for example are in lexington
kentucky
and tom clark's papers and out in the
truman library
roosevelt library you know we've spent
between the two of us
really endless months in different
libraries it's not just the johnson
library that you do the work
do you think that um london johnson
would be as anxious as he was to have a
library if he knew that
a lot of the material that is in that
library would end up in a book like this
what do you think he would react what
would he be his reaction to this book
oh i i you know lyndon johnson as we saw
as president did not take kindly to
criticism
however when he reads all four books
i think that uh when he sees the life as
a whole
he's likely to feel that i gave him
both in the bright sense as well as the
dark sense
his place in history you know
i wrote in the introduction to this book
that it was abraham lincoln who struck
the chains from black americans
but it was lyndon johnson who took them
by the hand
led them into the voting booth drew
democracy's curtain behind them
and made them once and for all and
forever a part of american political
life
that's coming it's not in this volume
but it's coming
by the way after going through all this
do you think the ends justify the means
i i can't answer that question i like
that
it's too complicated what i will say is
that this volume means of ascent
raises the great question of the
connection
between means and ends because many of
the ends of lyndon johnson's life were
noble
heroic advances i mean we wouldn't have
a lot of the civil rights legislation we
have today
if lyndon johnson hadn't pushed it
through
but he wouldn't have been in position
however that's not to say his presidency
was a triumphant presidency because it
divided the country it caused the
credibility gap it had a lot of dark
sides
but whatever the ends are good and bad
they wouldn't be possible if it wasn't
for the means
by which she got to a position to have
those ends which are in this fine
bottomless capacity for deceit deception
and betrayal yes was he a dishonest man
knowingly
well i don't know what knowingly means
you think he did these things and he
knew that he was doing
i think he was a man who had to win
i see in this i think we all see in this
volume
in this election a man who
had to win he uh you know
he had kidney stones during this
campaign
it was his last chance kidney stones are
a particularly agonizing pain
and this was a terrible attack and his
fever was 105 degrees and the doctors
told him you know you must get to a
hospital
you're risking the loss of a kidney
function in fact it goes on you're
risking the loss of your life
he wouldn't stop campaigning he was
laying he was driving back and forth
across texas
lying in the back of the car between
stops
gagging and wretching perspiration
pouring off them but every time they
pulled into a town he'd get on a clean
shirt
big smile and he bound out he'd shake
every hand and give the speech
when you use the word knowingly or
unknowingly i almost think it's
deeper than that with lyndon johnson he
simply had to win
before you leave the kidney stone story
tell the tell a little bit on the train
well the little bit on the train was
told to me by warren woodward who was a
young aide of lyndon johnson uh he's
coming back from this trip to the
panhandle
he has to come back to dallas because
secretary of the air force
stuart symington is flying to dallas to
let johnson announce with him a period
of press conference and announce with
him
that the air force base is going to stay
open on the plan
on the train coming back you see with
kidney stones and 105 degree fever you
have
ultimately terrible chills
and terrible fever so johnson was in a
pullman birth
woodward was across the aisle johnson
would really scream
woody woody i'm burning up i'm burning
up get open the window so woodward would
lean
across the him and with the porter they
they tugged the ends of the wind get the
window five minutes later johnson said
i'm freezing i'm freezing and
woodward and the porter would get all
the blankets and pile them on
then it would be freeze uh heat again
they raised the winner and finally
johnson
was so cold he said would he get into
bed with me hold me you know for body
warmth
and woodward did and johnson was just
shaking
he was so uh racked with fever and
chills
the fantastic thing about this was that
the next day
now woodward is a young man he doesn't
know what to do
symmington is coming up to johnson's
hotel room
woodward just can't get johnson to stop
he feels johnson may die
so he before woodward johnson's in the
bedroom
late rest when woodward locks at the
door uh
when simonton knocks at the door
woodward goes and whispers to him how
sick
johnson symington would never have known
it if wouldn't
woodward hadn't told him the door to the
bedroom opens
there's lyndon johnson big smile
ready to talk about the air force base
because he didn't want anything to
interfere
with the campaign i call that chapter
will
i think it's a triumph of the will
i knowingly and unknowingly i don't
think
even goes deep enough with lyndon
johnson in the lady bird chapter you
talk about his mistress
yeah did she know about his mistress i
don't know did you ask her about his
mistress no i didn't
why not i couldn't bear to
why well i think i just said
as a matter of fact uh
was that the only question you couldn't
ask her yes
how did you find out and how did you
verify the fact that he did it
oh well actually
her sister and her best friend
approached me
and said we've read the power broker
you seem to find out everything about
your subject
and we know you're going to find out
about alice and we don't want alice
portrayed as son bimbo she was a quite
unusual woman and she was very important
in lyndon johnson's life
and she was and i learned about her
from the sister from the best friend and
from i think
of four or five other sources who were
named in the book
and of course in the second volume we
even quote a letter during the war when
he was out on the coast
she visits him and
later you know writes jokingly to a
friend who
gave me the letter years later you know
when he's president says
let's jokingly she says let's
collaborate on a biography on lyndon
i can write the chapter on his war
service in hollywood where the hollywood
photographers were trying to teach him
which is the best side of his face
so there is no lack of you know every i
mean
it was not it was not a short affair it
was very important in his life
i felt you had to write about it for
two reasons number one she was very
important
in his life when he came to washington
he was a young
awkward gorky congressman he didn't know
how to dress you know he had long arms
the wrist stuck
out of his shirt and uh
she taught him how to dress she had a
very elegant salon
she had a wonderful estate
in the virginia hunt country and
she also was very astute politically
and there was a time in johnson's early
career where he was really
had a problem with his chief financial
backer herman brown of brown and ruth
and brown was a man that nobody crossed
and johnson
and him were on a collision course and
it was alice glass
who devised the compromise give herman
the dam and let linden have the land
which really saved his career in that
sense
did you write i can't remember the
details that
lady bird johnson and former president
johnson would spend
time at his mistresses yes they went
down
to well it was a great estate in
virginia
uh and they would both go down there and
on other occasions he would go down and
leave lady bird at home
so you don't know whether or not she
knew or not no i do not
this is really off the subject but
warren g harding
fdr john f kennedy lyndon johnson
must be leaving some general eisenhower
all rumored and some
there was evidence had mistresses what
is it about presidents
and mistresses poor men
i i don't know but in johnson's life
uh alice glass played a role you see his
entire character
emerged in some ways in his dealings you
know with alice glass
and uh when he goes to the pacific he
can't decide whether to file for the
senator to file for congress and it's
her
opinion he wants for years
i've heard a rumor around this town and
i don't think it's in the book here but
i want to ask you about whether or not
you ever found it
there in communication circles they were
all they always used to say that
there was one television station in
austin texas for a long time ktbc i know
you write about the radio station
uh that london johnson used to call fcc
commissioners and say if you keep that
one station there
and not allow any others and i'll put
you back on the commission did you ever
find any evidence that he
used the commission and the appointment
process when he was president
to keep control and the value in his
television station well i'm not up to
that yet and
so i can't answer when you say you're
not up to that would that be something
you write in another volume
yes i'm happy to talk about anything
i've written but not about stuff that i
haven't written
and i haven't i haven't finished my
research on the presidency
when is your next volume doing well
i'm writing it now i finished a lot of
the research on it
and i hope that this won't take so long
i'm really hoping that it'll be out in
two or three years
does this get any harder for you the
more you do this or is it easier
well it's sort of fascinating to be
honest with you because now the focus
shifts from texas i loved learning about
texas i missed stuck i mean i miss it
already
but washington is fascinating too
during this last i well before i
finished the last stage of writing i
used to sit in the senate gallery all
day
you know we'll walk around the cloak
rooms and the hideaways
just trying to get a sense of the senate
you know i felt like
they're staging this show the senator
needs to show that they're staging for
me
i love it to be honest have you noticed
people
treating you differently the more they
read your books the more visible you
become
well yes and i i you asking
i do people recognize you on the street
yes it doesn't happen to be something
that i'm really in love with
do you find people who don't agree with
you becoming
um i really had to put this question do
you find yourself being confronted
from time to time by people who don't
like what you're writing well you know
that goes through stages when the first
volume came out
and when the power broker came out
there's this wave
of controversy at the beginning but with
my first two books i learned
that after a very short time it all
fades away and blur is in your mind you
can't remember the review it's bad or
good
you can't remember whether you publish
you took enough ads or not you know
the only thing that's left is the book
and it seemed to me that in both cases
my first two books once people settled
down
to read what i really wrote
that that faded away and they just
became accepted
so that right now we're in the first
week after publication
or you know whatever you want to wear
monthly after publication
um and i hope this will be accepted
in the spirit that i wrote and in this
next volume you're not going to have the
help of your wife
is that going to make it is that going
to change the nature are you going to
have the same editor
um yes i i hope to always have the same
editor robert gottlieb was the editor
that he went from canaaf to the new
yorker
but he edited this book just like he did
the others
and i hope to have the same publishing
house
and i hope that ifina finishes her book
that she'll find time to help me on the
next one too because as i wrote
in the end of this book i don't know
what i'll do without it
the name of the book is the years of
lyndon johnson
means of ascent written by robert a
carrow
our guest for the last hour thank you
for joining us